- So Magic Mike Three,
it's happening, right?
- Yes.
- I heard that it's happening.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay.
You were trying to keep it from us.
- (laughs) I really did not.
- You're trying not to do it.
- I, you know what, if I'm moving here.
- Oh my gosh.
- [Channing] If I'm, oh God.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- [Channing] No, no, don't put that up.
- I would put that,
if I worked out and look like that,
I would put it up everywhere.
(Channing laughs)
- Trust me.
That might be the reason why
I didn't want to do a third one,
- [Kelly] Is it, do you?
- Is 'cause I have to look like that.
- So you don't work out
regularly all the time.
- No, but it's, it's hard to look like.
Even if you do work out,
to be that shape is,
- [Kelly] To be that kinda talented.
- Is not, it's not natural.
- Do you have to eat like so well?
- Yeah, you have to.
Not well, it's not even,
that's not even healthy.
You have to starve yourself.
- Oh my God.
- I don't think when you're that lean,
it's actually healthy.
- See, health is dangerous.
- It is, it's true.
(Kelly laughs)
New public service announcement, folks.
Health is not good for you.
- New PSA.
(Channing laughs)
This is why I don't work out.
I am just trying to save people here.
No, but what is it like
getting into shape for that?
Like is it that kind of hell?
- Like, yeah.
I mean, I, which truly, I don't know how
people that work a nine to
five actually stay in shape
because it's my full-time
job and I can barely do it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But it is.
If you work out twice a day
you have to eat completely right,
at a certain time.
It's a, it's a specific thing.
- It's a talent to be
able to do that as well.
Because even in like
when I have like vacation time,
I'm like, this is the time.
- [Channing] Yeah.
- I'm gonna do it.
No.
- [Channing] No.
- I don't do it.
- I fluctuate.
Like almost, I, it was a
lot more when I was younger
but now I can't, I can't get it off, so,
as easy.
- [Kelly] Oh.
So I fluctuate like 15 pounds,
but I used to fluctuate like 30.
- [Kelly] Age is not Fun.
- No.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And why when it takes
like, I don't know,
two months to get really lean,
but in like three days you can lose it?
- You can ruin it (laughs)
- It's gone. I was like,
whoa, what happened?
It was just the weekend.
- What's the thing that you miss most?
- [Channing] Yeah.
- Like what's the thing
you miss most?
- The thing I miss most
probably is like salt.
Like when.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Like when you need to get
really close to the like,
the day where you gotta
be butt naked on screen.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, and it is the day for me.
- Those days aren't for everyone.
- No,
(Kelly laughs)
salt is just like, you know, it goes,
you just, everything just tastes like
I don't know, tastes like water.
It's nothing.
- See, I'm a sweet person.
I, can't not.
- [Channing] Oh okay.
- Like when they're like, oh
you're not gonna be able
to have sugar on this diet.
I'm like, oh, I'm out.
(both laugh)
- Oh, see you later.
- I mean, I like monk fruit.
I like salad.
I like all the things you can like do.
But every once in a while,
I just want some good,
like Ben and Jerry's, so.
- Do you have to finish every
meal with like a sweet taste?
- No. No, but I don't.
But what I crave though,
every time I've done like a hardcore thing
is always like cake.
- [Channing] Yeah.
- Chocolate cake.
- [Channing] Cheat days.
- I want it right now.
- Yeah.
(both laugh)
I was actually at doing a, doing press,
doing a junket.
And, and so I was like, I'm
gonna give myself a treat.
And I ate like an entire two
pieces of chocolate cake.
And I was just like.
- [Kelly] Damn straight.
- But it was, as soon
as it hit like, my brain
I felt like immediately sick.
- Euphoric. Oh.
- It was euphoria.
And then immediately sick.
- Yeah.
- I was just like, oh, why did I do that?
- [Kelly] I know it's so bad for us.
- Yeah. It's terrible.
But it's delicious.
- Damn but it's so good.
- Why are the most delicious
things just horrible?
- I know.
That's just Satan.
(audience laughs)
So I, so I hear the new
magic, the Magic Mike movie
has more of a female point of view.
Is that true?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay. I'm interested.
- Yeah.
So like the first two
movies were about men
and kind of weirdly made for women.
So they were like these
feathered fish type films.
- [Kelly] Yes, we thank You.
(Channing laughs)
Yes.
- You're welcome. We thank you as well.
- It was a public service, I feel like.
(both laugh)
- Still trying to do our part really.
(audience applause)
- Just pleasing people. Doing God's work.
- Equal opportunity objectification, yes.
And I was like.
- But they're fun as well.
- Yeah.
I don't even actually think
just as that they're fun.
They're fun, and it's talent
to be able to dance like that.
That's no joke.
- Look We're just trying
to do our duty.
We're trying to.
- I agree.
But what's the female perspective,
how's that play?
- We, I really wanted
like a central character
that it was at least
an equal, if not more,
even more of a central character of Mike,
you know, 'cause it should be told
at some point through
a female's perspective
like what the world is and
how sex or freedom or relationships
kind of like evolve around her world.